so
it's not funny
so
some people have a deep abiding respect
for the constitutional law that created
this country
and some people don't
started liberalism
mud club can stop it.com
is
i get why ladies drink this way my mom
used to drink her lattes this way back
in french canada and it feels nice the
warm
the warm mug in the hand i don't know it
does
it warms the hand uh by the way everyone
happy thanksgiving yes gonna be a big
show uh thanksgiving of course i love
thanksgiving and uh i won't feel guilty
about it neither should you um we have a
lot that we're going to be talking about
today let me turn my headphones down a
little bit a lot we're going to be
talking about today we're a little late
because we wanted to do some research do
our due diligence
on daryl brooks jr the uh i keep wanting
to say shooter but then i realize you
don't need no you don't need a firearm
to commit
the car was mass murder um take away the
tragedy that the media is not covering
so we have
his social media posts we have his rap
sheet all of them we verified these
through court documents i would say the
social media posts 95 certain that these
are accurate we've verified the veracity
um
and
i just want you to be prepared today
we're also going to be talking about
elaine maxwell geelane elaine maxwell
the lady who helped underage sex
trafficking with jeffrey epstein yeah i
honestly thought it was just lane yeah
well it could be or that was her
nickname or it's a real name no i really
did think that i'm not even making a
cheap joke no she is what i would
normally oh mr landau you and your cheap
tricks
but uh
look there will be some what aboutism
today and i think it's entirely
appropriate what if because everyone
said what if kyle rittenhouse was black
what if and i will read these to you
today these were said about white people
what if kyle rittenhouse had said
anything like this mass murderer who was
absolutely racially motivated who had a
disdain for white people and i'm not
saying that black people are more racist
than white people or vice versa so what
i'm saying is that racism is a universal
problem and it has been exacerbated in
our lifetime by an irresponsible media
they want to blame the right wing for
saying that people from january 6
shouldn't be sentenced to four years in
prison for trespassing i think the media
is responsible for telling black people
that white people hate them in general
and the system is stacked against them
and it creates animosity that is not
productive for anyone and of course
they're not doing their work when it
comes to this man right now terrorist
attack i don't know racially motivated
100 so we'll talk about all of that but
before gerald a how are you i am doing
well on this thing thank you mr pilgrim
berries and cream happy thanksgiving
everyone good thank you he always wears
it it's gonna get dark really quickly
yeah as a matter of fact he's like mr
rogers he changes out of that into what
you see him on air yeah yeah
by the way we lost the map over here oh
you lost the map over here sorry let me
bring this back up we have a we also
have some technical difficulties here
today uh quarter black garrett how are
you what's up what's going on
i don't know what you're saying i don't
know you have a ponytail hey what do you
look like it's practical yeah okay you
actually
h and then he will be uh at the syracuse
funny practical he'll be at the syracuse
funny bone december 17th through 18th
the quickest man on his feet dave landau
how are you huh
ahoy ahoy
i'm great yeah wait a minute wait wait
wait a second but
i'm on you
but i'm on you
we're each
other uh it's available at
crowdershop.com too yeah all of these
boys and just so you know i hate my face
there is no show
i love well there's no live well
actually there is a show tomorrow by
popular request best riffs with dave and
i could be two or three hours so we want
you to have something to listen to
that's just pure laughs going into
thanksgiving and we'll be back the
monday after thanksgiving um yeah not
taking weeks off like bill maher bill
gotta go into hibernation bill maher is
always on vacation is this available at
crowder shop i mean dear god i hope not
outfit yeah it's like gerald's guys come
on let me get through we're not the view
we're not
oh listen i don't know what uh you know
uh kyle written now it's like my
ex-husband doesn't wash his feet what
are you saying i thought we'd call this
man the view yes
i'm republican um i'm a republican and a
navarro why in what way i don't know i
have to fill a place i have to fill a
place i am a place holder like the car
when you go to the rehearsal dinner that
you don't want crazy
that's me
email person
anna nevado republican so if you don't
see the show on youtube we have no idea
what's going to happen yeah at any given
time we stream monday through thursday
10 a.m eastern you can watch it on
rumble you can watch it of course on mug
club loudwriter.com club there's another
hour and a half hour every day today
we'll be playing newest gender pronouns
which as you well know could never be
played on youtube
but before we uh get into everything
here
uh
i guess now um this is something from uh
uh leftist on tiktok
uh uh
it's a new outrage every day here we go
so i have this thing oh quirk if you
will i have hair in my armpit i have it
there for a few reasons you must be very
proud of yourself two [ __ ] the
patriarchy and three
your response to them tells me
everything i need to know about you yeah
also you look like clint howard when he
played the asian baby
i like her sideburns yes yes exactly i'm
not you know what i love in a woman you
know what i look for is good mutton
chops yeah i've always said that i'm not
so much concerned about the hair under
the armpits it's the lack of hair on
three quarters of your head i want you
to wait i want you to look like
groundskeeper willie yes
exactly yes i want you to look like the
last emperor yes can we do that
oh you know what that's true she is
asian we didn't take that into account
yeah exactly is that not cultural
appropriation sorry oddly enough i
didn't notice her race i was too busy
noticing everything else that's nonsense
well listen don't buy anything from her
in a shop that you need to feed after
midnight
so especially her
i'll take my chances with a mogwai over
that yes
by the way hey question you guys comment
below um
why do you think it is that the media
has not reported at all
on daryl brooks jr's past racism and it
is racism yeah yeah if someone is
intensely racist and you don't call it
out
that usually means that you are racist
if you don't call it out whether it's
actual racism if you call out racism
where it doesn't exist with cal written
house and there was that interview in
tucker carlson i thought he did a great
job and then you
you cease to call out racism you you are
incapable of calling it out when someone
says that they hate white people and
they will run people over namely white
people and we'll get to this in a second
i think it means that you're racist
like charles manson some people on the
left are looking for a race war and i
just hope that we can avoid it at all
costs listen black white you're welcome
to watch this show you're welcome to
come to our live shows dave's live shows
we just ask that you don't burn stuff
down that's true don't be a racist dirt
[ __ ]
it's a blanket rule yeah forever hard
metaphorically you can burn the house
down yes well bring that i encourage
that yes absolutely bring it down i
don't know for allowed to say that
because we're white um that's cultural
appropriation let's not talk about black
santa so beta o'rourke let's talk about
this quickly is uh pandering as you know
for the latino vote yeah speaking of
cultural appropriations and people don't
realize how conservative a lot of
southern uh hispanic or mexican-american
ranchers are like all of them yeah well
this guy confronted beto and i don't
usually do the gotcha stuff
but this guy is fantastic let's watch it
i'm robert
i'm native native roberts
thank you for being behalf of the
ranchers and oil and gas and farmers yes
maxine water oh yeah i'm in your grill
telling you don't come back
thank you
thank you
watch this
i love that guy how embarrassed is the
guy with a rape whistle
oh my gosh yeah that's really all he can
do is blow a whistle at him take that
take it
this will be a slightly shrill sound
it's okay i'm immune i listen to the
view bro
it's fine
i love that he's like i think i'm gonna
lose oh man they don't like me here hey
robert
i love that
i love when somebody's being insulted
but he won't let go of his hand yeah
it's like the extra layer i think he
even said thank you after he was like
get the hell out oh yeah he's so scared
he's like this yes thank you yes thank
you come take my gun yeah come take my
gun a real mexican i can't i can't kick
flip my way out of this one
you want my gun muchacho no in spanish
sorry people out there are going to be
pissed off that we're not transitioning
well see ya friend really
it's usually a friendly thing it could
be bad i think he meant it ironically
he's a hipster mexican rancher i think
what do you got for me this is it's a
chicano slang hispanic youth guy dude
yeah yeah oh yeah but it's in a friendly
one when i was in the latin counts yes
it's thanksgiving so we do have some
good news for you uh-huh
warning we don't uh
sorry but
former vice president joe biden
delivered this in time for thanksgiving
now after years of wages being flat or
falling behind we're also seeing
something else inflation things are
getting better for american workers
printing much higher wages okay so let
me just say this fact check
technic fact check technically kind of
true
but let me give you some context uh so
first off under donald trump hourly
earnings increased uh to a high of 23.38
between 2018 2019 that's a 1.7 percent
increase when adjusted for inflation
here's the thing unprecedented hourly
earnings is not the metric that is most
accurate talked about this you can
search it we have all references of
course available at loderwithcredit.com
the link in the description um average
household income is a more
important metric why well look
the job of flipping a burger is not
worth twice what it was worth 10 years
ago when adjusted for inflation that job
is worth a set amount hourly however
average annual earnings takes into
account people who are promoted people
who move it takes into account all of
these different facets your age right
that's one of the biggest determining
factors in how much you make and with
donald trump average household incomes
increased by 5 dollars in three years
compared to one thousand under obama for
eight years
um and here's the real truth about joe
biden's quote real average hourly
earnings when accounting for inflation
that little
pesky devil that rep scallion
decreased by 0.5 percent for the month
because of a 0.9 percent inflation
increase which negated the 0.4
basically your money is worth less today
than it was yesterday not a joke
it's entirely yeah and
i believe that uh the wages went up
during trump because people were doing
well people were working so it was sort
of uh voluntary yes it was yes exactly
you mean the government wasn't just
handing out money that they had just
printed hot presses well they did that
too
but it wasn't their sole plan oh okay
hey if we can just increase if we can
just print more money
why tax any
yeah really i personally like to know
well we're gonna tax you uh yeah we're
gonna have to increase your taxes 24
come on and then we're gonna print uh
another couple trillion and we know that
to the penny
this will be paid for how do you know
oh
girls in the shower come on it's like if
i make everyone a sandwich and then i
just take all the sandwiches and i'm
like you can't have a sandwich tomorrow
either
you're like well why'd you make so many
and you're like i don't know i don't
know and then you're like everybody had
sandwiches it's just like this build
back better people say well there's a
lot of good in there that americans like
sure but there's a lot in there that
completely subverts the institutions of
a constitutional republic if someone
said hey i have a stew
and it's you know most of it is beef and
barley so that sounds delicious and
there's one percent [ __ ] human [ __ ]
would you say what can we just just take
the whole stew i think we should
one piece of human [ __ ] doesn't spoil
the whole stew no no no it actually does
listeria doesn't carry your color or
creed
like what if i don't eat it well it'll
ferment yes and in about a year it'll be
all [ __ ] yeah just put it in wine sacks
see what happens
i'd have it now if i were you you can't
put new wine [ __ ] in wine sex yes that's
something in the bible about wine skins
i don't know uh by the way it also means
that your holiday is going to be a
little bit pricier here at thanksgiving
i think everybody knows that and i don't
just mean for those who are commuting uh
with uh you know
what decade high gas prices but here's
the thing don't be don't be bothered
because the nbc uh folks over there the
reporters who are just like you
yeah just like you have some helpful
advice for thanksgiving and while we are
on the topic of something that could be
controversial
perhaps forego the turkey
bear with me
is the staple of the thanksgiving meal
however some people think turkey is
overrated and so it tends to be the most
expensive thing on the table maybe you
do an italian feast instead i will say
this
if you tell everyone you're having a
thanksgiving without turkey
some guests may drop off the list and
that's a way to cut costs too yeah take
granny off dialysis there's a way to cut
costs yeah don't hang out with your
family
maybe you don't like them anyway yeah
that's been time alone that'll say
wait i hear a ball what is it what is
that
noise oh what the hell white man in the
spirit of thanksgiving i want to give
you the sacred gift of tobacco oh i want
to trade with you oh well thank you
thank you very much i i just i only um
i only wish that we had uh something to
um yeah i think we got something to give
you oh wow maybe we've got something
hold on hold on yeah yeah you know what
hey yeah fire water over there for uh is
that our first nation
i don't know let's get rid of that
scalp uh we all did it oh there's oh oh
there's some there's another one yeah
yeah there you go you got some wild
turkey over there
i think i have something for you here oh
okay well i don't know all i have is
these uh
oh jeez these old blankets yeah uh and
um oh you know oh perfect actually um
look i come bearing the gift
of built bars
look at that
yes build bars uh if you don't know your
people those are actually their
fantastic protein bars low carbohydrate
and they have a real chocolate in there
yeah they almost like desserts i just
like this oh okay well thank you there's
plenty of antioxidants in that wild
turkey as well plenty of antioxidants in
that wild turkey oh okay what is he
doing uh yeah no no we'll do that we'll
we'll we'll come back to him later i
think oh god
that's enough that's enough that's
enough uh builtbar.com
built.com
fifteen percent bill your next order uh
oh god this it's yeah you get it off it
there's so much did he leave a scalp hey
we all did it well no we didn't i think
that's not the same way
you get 15 off i really do i eat them uh
i eat them i use them as a candy bar and
make sure that token that he understands
uh you know that uh he'll about what's
happening later in the show uh before we
uh move on here fantastic fantastic
stuff
this is gonna make a headline somewhere
back in 2017
while we're talking about thanksgiving
because some people want to do away with
thanksgiving yeah yeah i don't
understand why people are and by the way
the pilgrims did exchange peacefully
with the native when you're talking
about thanksgiving this is this long
predates
a lot of the wars that happen in the
battles i just don't know when people
say give the land back
which which one to who which tribe i
don't know is the fault only that the
last people standing do you have any
idea how viciously native american
tribes fought for a very long time the
only reason that some native americans
live in certain areas just because they
sided up with the colonialists to try
and protect themselves against other
natives who were killing their wives and
children and enslaving them just to be
clear so nothing really bothered i
shouldn't say nothing bothers me more
chlamydia but it's very bothersome
when you see the first nations i'm like
well ha ha a second but he's an iroquois
you're a huron
he said like he's algonquin you're
comanche do you have any idea do you
have any idea what do you guys think
player yes
saint claire anyway speaking of
traditions that we have to do away with
remember in 2017 when john oliver mocked
president trump for claiming that uh you
know statues where does it end with
statues coming down here you go a
refresher statues are how we glorify
people or in the case of one in tokyo
how we glorify giant radioactive lizards
and yet the president's concern seems to
be that tearing down statues leads to a
slippery slope this week it's robert e
lee i noticed that stonewall jackson's
coming down i wonder is it george
washington next week and is it thomas
jefferson the week after you know you
you really do have to ask yourself where
does it stop okay well i'll tell you
where it stops somewhere
anytime someone asks where does it stop
the answer is always [ __ ] somewhere
it's always nice to be john oliver and
not have to actually draw the line or
put yeah or answer the question sign
your name or have an argument to hold
accountability it ends somewhere really
where oh don't know but what should we
do this other joke about tilda swinton
[ __ ] you
you know his audience like did you hear
the tentative laughter like is this
supposed to be funny i think he is funny
but that being said hey that wasn't they
were saying it would only end with the
confederates for the first time now in
city hall the statue of thomas jefferson
uh i believe in new york city uh gone
here you go
now let me be clear are you serious yes
yeah i feel better already yeah
yeah this country to see so much better
now yeah it's so much better to get rid
of look i'd love to show them the future
too in 2017 and be like you want to see
where it ends yeah he
doesn't care somewhere here's
get used to it go back to him in 2013
and say hey by the way men are going to
be able to compete professionally as
women in combat sports well
that's just using a slippery slope
argument sure i am and by the way the
international olympic committee just now
said uh you don't even have to lower
your hormone levels oh well that's it so
that was kind of the one argument they
always use like my hormone levels have
been the same of a woman for a year it
doesn't change now you don't even have
to do that a year they punch it to the
sports they don't punt steroid use for
men to sports but you know what yeah
tomato testosterone now here to be clear
the reason they're get-ridding uh
get-ridding the reason they are getting
rid of uh thomas jefferson
on the idea
that he uh owns slaves and that's
absolutely true
so did everybody back then now keep in
mind that thomas jefferson vocally
aboard the practice of slavery he said
that we would never be able to live up
to our ideals as a nation of all men
created equal with the concept of
slavery he freed two slaves during his
life and he freed more after he died uh
he was the only one he wasn't actually
able to free all them because he had had
debts yeah he would you know he it's
yeah i mean he bet on the he been on the
lions
he did nobody should do he wrote 198
word anti-slavery passage for the
declaration of indi independence he
condemned slavery as an evil foisted
upon the colonies by the crown here's
what he wrote he has waged cruel war
against human nature himself violating
its most sacred rights of life and
liberty in the persons of a distant
people who never offended him
captivating and carrying them into
slavery in another hemisphere or to
incur miserable death in their
transportation thither that's a nice
word
it's very frequently influenced
this is the guy who literally brought
the idea and the phrase all men are
created equal to our country yeah this
is the guy
who did that slavery existed at that
point yeah you can't do away with it in
a day he did everything that he could at
that point no one's perfect well not
only that it was completely what was
going on during like that's what it was
it was there was no other way to live
that's how it was that's how people saw
them yeah and he saw them as people when
other people frankly didn't right they
saw them as equipment and it's sad but
that's just what it was what's funny to
me is when you have african-americans
who have no connection to the you know
what as referred to as the motherland
muhammad ali richard pryor that's what
they would refer to africa as the
continent um they'll wear this this this
garb that often will be representative
countries that still have some form of
slavery and servitude or they say you
can't do we say nancy pelosi can't wear
the scarf yeah you're wearing the
uniform of the people that sold
people into slavery as well first slave
owner in america was black yep look
people get mad slavery was never
racially motivated there were racial
components used afterwards to justify it
just like people perverted the bible but
there were white people who were
enslaved there were mediterranean people
who weren't so if you look at the north
african slave trade in china other asian
people were enslaved other chinese
people were enslaved if you look at the
history with the mongols with the
japanese this is something in other
words people have enslaved other people
who they've conquered since the
beginning of time
the united states freed slaves
with without conquering that's that's
one thing too that's that's surprising
that's singularly unique about the
united states of america we fought a war
to free slaves which many people would
argue would have been to the benefit of
the oppressors where else can you think
of oppressors fighting a war to end
their own reign of oppression you're
welcome
by the way we're going to do the julian
maxwell segment after uh it says that
here in the map we're gonna do it after
the uh uh uh waukesha so let's make sure
we move this here um okay let's get into
the waukesha update uh what are they do
i don't mean to uh
but anyway sorry what what are they
doing with the statue
i got a thomas jefferson statue how you
use the carpool lane right someone just
puts a feather hat on i'm like hey this
is uh this is no this is a general uh
this is chief big bear
it looks like thomas jefferson ah i
don't know anything about that used to
be never heard of them yeah that's
awesome by the way would you like a gun
while you're here we have diamonds we
have guns and this uh thomas jeffrey
tobacco story
listen i think texas would love to
proudly display the person who
contributed so much to the united states
of america making it to where it is yes
i think we would love the statue in the
great state of texas so if it's going in
mothballs new york you got a willing
buyer
yeah i don't i mean doesn't new york
have other problems
no not at all no no i i lived there i
always felt safe yes yes
look i know you know what's going to
solve the boarded up shops on fifth and
uh really the entire city
getting rid of the man who said all men
are created equal let's get rid of that
statue let's make sure that uh we have a
priority straight hey you hey hey hey
cuomo stop grabbing the tits of that
intern no uh as a statue gun i think
we're good yes perhaps uh the statue
will be raped and murdered in one of
their many parks yes exactly yeah well
you know what
we
we abandon old traditions to make way
for new traditions exactly you can just
destroy the bat signal now everything's
good yes you don't need
the cuomo signal it's just a penis yeah
so control room make sure you guys move
the maxwell thing are we good there took
it on you guys got it
you don't need to do it make sure
control room does it okay look here i
want to get into uh waukesha
what happened yesterday we were here
live while cnn's was still saying he or
her uh and of course the
suspect the criminal the mass murderer
in in question
uh had been identified and we brought
that to ulcn i guess either they don't
know how to do their job or they're
lying you have to pick one he or she yes
you are fake news so we did some more
digging on the suspect and i i think
this is really important i want this to
be uh sort of uh i guess a capsule where
you can get all the information that you
need to because there's a lot of
information out there and i will tell
you i do this for a living it's hard to
parse through what's real and what's
fake and there have been some fake
reports coming from both the left and
the right i would say in this case there
have been a lot on the right who've
jumped on information that they have not
confirmed so pretty confident everything
that we're confirming here we'll make
this all available at loudercutter.com
and i want to
bring one thing to your attention here
keep in mind that kyle rittenhouse
voluntarily gave his phone over yeah to
the authorities
they went through it with a fine-tooth
comb
and didn't even find a meme
that's that's crazy on a 17 year old's
phone right
they found nothing can any of you say
that
no they found absolutely nothing and so
when they say that his
self-defense was racially motivated i'm
going to bring to you the criminal
record and what this man daryl brooks jr
who mowed down women and children i
don't know what the death toll is up to
now last i checked it was
it was five maybe six and there are kids
in critical condition god
thoughts and prayers will say is that
all you have to offer that's about all i
have to offer right now it's better than
you offering nothing
it's just heartbreaking it's absolutely
heartbreaking so i do want you to think
what if uh in this case
this man was white and what he had said
i think it's entirely appropriate
because we've been playing the what if
game for a while hold on i have to make
sure i find this okay so uh
five deaths by the way yeah okay five
deaths four females one male 18 children
hospitalized ages eight three to sixteen
um
anyway
that's just it's heartbreaking so daryl
brooks jr uh math boyfly was one of his
social media uh account names so if you
see that on screen that's darryl brooks
jr math boy he's been charged
uh what did i say no you said that i'm
like math sorry math boy with an eye
not grammar boy yeah
it's not a key it's not aquila in the b
folks there's this is real life there's
no uh lawrence fishburne
so uh it's not family matters
he's been charged with 11 crimes going
back to 1999. so let me give you there's
a problem first with cash bail there's a
problem here with us people say we need
to reform the prison system and for some
reason we always assume that it's
because we have too many people
incarcerated well we actually have a
problem where people who need to be
incarcerated for longer periods of time
cannot be let out on the street to harm
people i think that the criteria should
be is this person violent
are they a threat to other people
violently are they a flight risk
let's start with that and in this case
the man was uh in all of those
categories checked every box ding ding
ding so
uh let's go back through his crimes math
uh substantial battery intended bodily
harm a classy felony in 2010
strangulation and suffocation 2008
statutory sexual seduction 2011
resisting or obstructing an officer last
year he was charged with two counts of
recklessly endangering safety with a
dangerous weapon and one count of
illegally possessing a firearm on
november 5th he was charged with
recklessly endangering safety domestic
violence and bail jumping there was also
a charge where he tried to run over the
mother of his child with his car
on november 5th this is not the first
time he's tried to run over someone with
his car there's also a police report
where when police tried to arrest him he
tried to run over one of those officers
with his car it's his car all the all
the greats have their calling guard
and then he was released on november
11th
thousand dollar bail
thousand dollar bills pretty low he
accept this bail john chris home is
somewhat of a he's somewhat of a
progressive hero uh 2015 um
also
serial masturbator i know it's hard if i
say jeffrey tube and you say who we
can't bring up a picture of his dick i
know that would be easier to identify
him
uh he said about this d.a
chisholm stuck his neck out there and
started saying that prosecutors should
also be judged by their success in
reducing mass incarceration and ensu
achieving racial equity just i believe
yesterday aoc was talking about how we
need to be reducing sentences and make
it easier for the underprivileged to get
out look how about this if we use the
criteria are you violent are you a
threat to people are you a flight risk
it doesn't matter if you're rich or poor
you're not getting out
yeah yeah but if you see it through the
lens of race oh a guy with suffocation
charges and trying to run people over i
always see that as underprivileged yes
that's the issue there well an aoc's you
know think she was like well this
disproportionately affects poor people
i'm like no it disproportionately
affects criminal [ __ ] yeah no it
disproportions well it
disproportionately affects uh people who
get run over with their cars well that's
domestic uh abusers like jacob blake
keep in mind who digitally raped the
woman who were who's restraining order
he was violating at that moment before
he reached for a knife with the cops a
rosenbaum a pedo who gets out the day he
dies for some reason yeah i don't i mean
you know look
it's just happened stance
just a roll of the dice it's just a roll
of the pedophile dice a thousand dollars
bail and you pay 10 i believe yeah yeah
that means that guy had to come up with
100 big ones uh i think it was a i think
it was a thousand on ten thousand
dollars what he had to pay is that what
he had to pay the bond okay so
western union made a killing
um
not really so let's go to a social media
post because people are saying we don't
know anything about his motivation yeah
now again i ask you what if math boy
what if
daryl brooks jr
was white
would have been continually released
because again the idea of this d.a of
what aoc they say we need to make sure
that these offenders are more easily
released back into the public because
they're underprivileged if they're black
they see it through the prism of race
what if he was white
now let's go through the social media
accounts we have no idea as to the
inspiration of this guy it's not a
terrorist incident keep that in mind
kyle rittenhouse nothing on his phone
and by the way before i move on smash
that like button on youtube right now
and share this out if you can because
not to go through some info that
might get us in trouble it's all
documented we have no idea what
youtube's going to do anything you can
do to share and let people know they
need to be hearing this yeah uh here are
some of the posts uh from math boy
he wrote learned nd taught behavior so
when we start back knocking white people
tf ion wanna hear it the old hey uh
quarter black garrett you understand
this a little bit better yeah let me let
me see here yeah
learned so learned and taught behavior
so the phrase learned in top behavior so
when we switch switch white people with
black people here though just to make
yeah oh oh yeah yeah okay
when we start
back knocking black people
the [ __ ]
i ain't want hear it
the white no sorry the black people we
got
the old black people the old black
people
people
this is difficult to read yeah people
too it's almost like the man knocked him
the [ __ ] out
period yep you got knocked up yes so
he's saying go knock out
just to be clear yeah go knock out old
white people again
what if
he was a white guy and he said this
about black people would we not be
calling it domestic terrorism let me
read another one november 18 2015 post
when something happens to white america
they want an eye for an eye when
something happens to black america we
are told to pray about it and let it go
that's not accurate november 18th 2015.
it's not true melaninated worldwide
revolution
and you can see some of the posts for
people who are listening uh listening on
audio sounds like black supremacy uh
august 29 2016 white people outraged
after gabby douglas doesn't put her hand
over her heart during the national
anthem we have november 4th 2015
question why are we so complacent with
our oppression until we hate oppression
more than we hate each other nothing
will change
may 13 2017 this is not the home of the
free and land of the brave it's the land
of the stolen and the home of the slave
november 9th 2015 on facebook laws
legally allowing white supremacy what if
he had said laws legally allowing the
catch and release of black supremacist
again i ask you what if this switch
everything here that says white which he
does multiple times with black because
we were just told that kyle rittenhouse
was a racist who shot three white people
if he wrote that he wouldn't have
understood what an acronym is i will you
could be correct yes if anything his his
bail should have been set higher for
grammatical infractions
february 20th this is very hard and
that's what it is there are very
instances where i'm going to read this
word for word february 23rd 2016. cops
instructions on how to kill black people
and he has a whole post
then he says this
run them over
and then he goes on to say later since
they are trying to block the street you
should not be charged with anything
then january 8 2016 he wrote repeat
after me i thought he had a gun he
reached for his waistband i feared for
my life this is him saying that white
officers are being trained to simply go
out and kill black people
these three phrases will ensure that you
can kill anyone you want and no jury
will convict you
and then he said on january 1st 2016 no
matter how much you trust the police
always remember the police are trained
to never trust you and here we have a
collage of more posts without words that
are uh obviously racist and um this is
look
not only is it racist let's assume
because not everyone is a horrible black
supremacist as this person is who goes
out to kill white people but there are a
lot of black people who if they believe
that the cops are out there to kill you
if they believe that the system is
designed to kill black people and
execute them without any sort of
justification just like you know we
always said if you call conservatives if
you call every trump voter or nazi well
guess what it makes treating those
people
sub-humanely acceptable who here
wouldn't punch an actual nazi who
who enjoyed gassing jews who here
would not want an armed revolution if
they believed that the police were were
being taught to go out through black
neighborhoods and kill you who here
would have a problem with that if you
actually believed it he believes this
some of these are reposts from other
media outlets to be clear he is when we
talk about the radicalizing think about
this for a second the new york times did
an article about the radicalizing
of the right with the young right wing
and they had a picture
of dave rubin and philip defranco
that was considered radicalization
this is considered
radicalization this guy is parroting
what you hear on cnn and aoc's feed how
is that not radicalization it is far
worse than saying hey hey hold on a
second all men created equal and i don't
think that we should be uh basically
subscribing to critical race theory as
it's known now black liberation theology
identity politics right moral relativism
that's considered more extreme than run
them over that's considered more extreme
than knock old people old white people
the [ __ ] out
let's be really really clear about this
this is evil stuff this is ugly stuff
and this guy believed it and this guy
acted on it
and this guy's been encouraged by what
he's seen
to go out and do it yeah there's no
consequences to stuff like this and
eventually it leads you to being so
frustrated that you're like screw it i
don't we should be clear we're not
saying there are no consequences to
running people over that's what we're
saying is yes there are no consequences
to posting these things on social media
well there's very little immediate
consequence when the media just goes to
defending you well no the immediate the
consequences i'm talking about of his
previous behaviors his previous law
breaking behaviors have apparently not
had a ton of consequences associated
with him because he's back out a bail
jumper as i said yesterday i was like
holy crap you don't need to be a crack
detective to go maybe we should keep
this guy here because he's got bail
jumper in his bio and he's a felon and
he's he trafficked underage
women yeah and i feel like you should do
i don't know less than five years ago
that was yeah what six years ago yeah i
feel like you should do more time than
that yeah
yeah i think you should do more time
shouldn't you at least do the person's
age that's a good idea ouch yeah and no
seriously and no solitary they put you
in the rapist ward and they unlock your
cell yeah that's the best they should do
that anyway they should absolutely do
that yeah then you can do a week yep
because you won't make a son it's like
fleet week pop that ass oh jeez i'm
sorry what no no no no no that's just
hateful when we're talking about someone
who trafficked underage miners and
choked and strangled and uh and uh tried
to run people over with his car we
wouldn't want to be distasteful could
you call him a gentleman yeah yeah let's
call him a gentleman well gentle person
he or she sorry you're right we don't
know we're sideburns girl there'd be no
way of knowing and by the way we also
did some digging and uh the guy fancied
himself a uh one of those rappers
oh did he one of those very rare
breakthrough rapper
one of these breakthrough wrapping cases
and uh funded by the government i have
no idea like the other one you have an
airbnb if it weren't enough we just put
together some of his again all
references available you can look at the
link in the description of his
soundcloud songs where he talks about
being a terrorist where he talks about
killing white people here's a nice
little let's call it a remix a
proclamation using every type of
deceptive method to further us into
slavery uh called second-class
citizenship i think that it would take a
whole lot of nerve for white people
today to ask negroes do they hate them
this that malcolm x
revolutionary
[ __ ] in the can eating conversation
for every ghetto in them hey you know
what pause pause there quarterback
uh if i get copyright
struck yeah for this [ __ ]
i am going to be livid uh you know what
tim the toolman on audio there can you
you know just uh add your own uh
flavor to it add some stuff so that was
transformative yeah yeah
these devils
it keeps going it does he just keeps
flowing
down you don't want it no you scared of
this about that action anywhere yeah
oh he's a terrorist yeah he admitted
i hope you write with god cause the
oh
sure it's not a joke okay keep in mind
we said we should have seen the warning
signs of the columbine shooters because
they played doom
well do you you never heard uh dylan
klebel's
rap track
his ska band was really scavenged yes
it's called real big terrorists yes it
was
actually i think the the shooting was
better than most ska
what happened
i'm sorry
so in other words we talk about warning
signs right was this man radicalized
right if it's
can i say one thing it's important uh
with malcolm x i think people do not
understand malcolm x watched his father
get tied to a train track in lansing by
the kkk and killed he had reason to have
hate now if you read his biography and
actually take time to look into the man
he did at the end of his life feel that
everybody was equal he had said that he
made a lot of mistakes violence was not
the answer malcolm x was an extremely
intelligent guy and he's one of them he
really is one of the people used
completely incorrectly in history for
what his belief ended up being and when
he did change to peace he was killed
yeah yeah by his own group of people
keep in mind when you listen to this
gentleman he or her he decides to align
with the malcolm x period the fermenting
hatred period yeah yeah that's the issue
is is yeah you have people who use it
on the left black liberation theologist
critical race theorists right and they
ignore the latter half of his life and
so then unfortunately people on the
right have to acknowledge the
inspiration of malcolm x it would be
nice just like i've talked about with
you know uh muhammad ali muhammad ali
voted for ronald reagan he campaigned
for oren hatch
well
no one knows that he campaigned for oren
hatch well and malcolm x's nickname was
red do you know why because he was part
white
and that was another thing that i don't
understand why that would be red well
he's a mixed community member he had he
had red hair oh one of those dinos he
died yeah it wasn't natural he's he's
one of my brothers yes but he yeah he's
a quarterby yeah yeah
except he was closer to half b yes yeah
but yeah he he was somebody who eyeball
test he also dealt with that in his life
like he has a very like i wrote his
biography not that i'm an expert on it
but it just it is amazing to see how in
in incorrectly he's used yeah he's in
he's used incorrectly by both sides
unfortunately his legacy to the black
community
it could be much better yeah what
they've chosen the worst part yeah
they've chosen the low lights this is
what i mean by that solidify cons of the
world yes even barack obama by the way
that group this year that group i should
say of people i don't know really
something
yeah very peaceful nation of islam
mostly peaceful yeah sorry mostly not
about the jews well
hey when we talk about anti-asian crimes
it must be white people when we talk
about anti-semitism you can go
to fair farrakhan's congregation on any
given day that he's speaking
and see worse than what you've seen in
american history x and people are like
ah you know what are we going to do
what do you do
it's a problem monetize how about you
cover it how about we start with that
hey media how about you cover this this
is one of those things where you can't
say we didn't know really you had no
idea that this guy was going to do it i
don't know i i i would have had a hunch
if i were for example the fbi or the
authorities but they were too busy
covering up drone footage in the written
house trial i would say you know what i
think we might we might see something
coming down the pike with this guy that
could be bad why because he says he's
going to kill white people and run
people over with his car also he's
trying to do it twice so i don't know if
that's enough for a case
he's also incredibly racist yes we've
got some parents though that care about
their kids so we need to investigate
them instead we can't right but did you
hear his flow i mean i play it on a loop
come on it's hard out here for a shitty
race maybe if white people could rap a
little better yeah black snake groan
so it's not even a movie about hip hop
three sucks mafia
oh
that was oscillating flow
bone pugs
i'm saying what i'm saying for this guy
both of you stop this room just got
whiter
very white
stop very quick is that possible gerald
you know
better than what you just did i do on
purpose i know he knows rap very well
you look at him you wouldn't think that
dressed like a pilgrim yeah well you
know we love to get down yeah he was
ghetto oh my gosh that movement with
that blonde hair blue eyes is the face
that weinstein sees in his night but
picture him without that tooth yeah
now he's ghetto yep
yeah funny is when i first met him he
was missing it too i know i was shout
out with a bit oh that's what i'm
referencing people don't realize that
was my street cred man that's what i
mean he's hood i took a bullet to the
mouth yeah what happened to you what
happened literally got shot in the mouth
you took a pellet
stop
it looked like a rifle and it shot a it
shot a projectile and so i don't know if
you guys are going to get upset about
this
before i get to
delane maxwell
i used to have conversations with my
wife then fiance because gerald was
missing a tooth
and
my wife and i be like
how do we tell them to fix that because
you were single and we were like i don't
know that could be no that's i'm not
saying it's only that but that's a
component and my wife and i had
conversations as to how we would bring
it up because we just thought it rotted
out of your skull no and then when i
found out you had this backstory that it
was shot out with a pellet i'm like oh
well then he knows this wasn't by choice
or neglect it was my assault i thought
it was laffy taffy yes how do i neglect
one tooth i don't know oh you got a lot
of them in there maybe you have weird
russian technique yeah you just didn't
brush water i'm kind of missed as i'm
transferring over every single day of my
life i didn't order ben shapiro's
electric quip
but whenever you see like
somebody who's missing like a front
tooth you're surprised if they're in
like a new shirt because you're like
shouldn't that just go in the two yeah
yeah exactly like everything should be
tooth fun then everything else yeah
did you just put subwoofers in your car
yes why you want to rattle the one next
to it
exactly
what's the matter with you did you just
spend eight hundred dollars on a back
tattoo that no one will ever see i feel
like if you have one tooth that's very
possible buy yourself a pair of pliers
wedge it back in there yes oh man is
that a lower back tattoo well i couldn't
fix the tooth so i just wanted to look
like i had tried this i wanted to set
the look fit the rest of it you know i
went for a banana republic sale and i
just knocked this one to even it out
yeah at that point you might as well
just put suspenders on a garbage can
over there
we love that you have your teeth back no
so do i it was i was just too poor to
fix it but i just joke he actually knows
a ton about hip hop we've talked that's
why it just it surprises people when i
start singing like you know 90s hip-hop
and they're like wait what
you don't sing 90s hip-hop
so it depends if you're well if you're
like the nate dog part you certainly do
all right not going to rap we have to
move on to jalane maxwell's
sex traffickers so look no one's paying
attention to this the jury selection is
starting this week for people who don't
know galen maxwell jeffrey epstein's
accomplice in underage sex trafficking
yeah but at this point it really could
have been uh uh daryl brooks jr or it
could have been rosenbaum or it could
have been that uh other person from
kenosha who was a crystal uh i can't
remember her name killed it seems like
we have a we have an epidemic crystal
kaiser have an epidemic of underage sex
trafficking yeah who knew
how are these people keep how do they
keep getting out oh that's okay that's
right that's right uh bail ah
dang it we've talked about it's like i
forgot what i talked about not too long
ago yeah i mean it's short-term memory
loss from being assaulted with
never-ending evil right insanely
low-bail that's right i forget right i
forgot but you didn't happen to what is
it you didn't happen to traffic underage
minors for sex with the most deplorable
people on earth did you uh yes well look
that's a thousand dollars for you and uh
let's just promise you won't do it again
for the uh fifth time yes also no more
running over anyone with your ford
escape come on now i thought it was
underage old prospectors yes that's why
i set the bail so long we talked about
this wrong kind of minor that court in
batman that was sentencing him to walk
out on the ice seems very reasonable now
really
that really is
really i think you're lying that is the
best court ever though that should be
pedophile court yeah pedophile of course
you'll see it's just dying in the ice
like i don't want to walk out in the ice
again what what's that acro what's that
across the pond there you just have the
hearty boys
go help them light that campfire all
right and then they go through just a
kid picking up a quarter and he's like
wow
crack fall
and then he ends up in pedophile hell
which is just uh it's just earth without
yeah we've been there yeah
that's all it is there is a buffet but
there's just no kids no gary coleman is
a full age richard pryor like oh no
oh
they've taken everything i loved
gary coleman's six foot three in
pedophile hell yes exactly no i like the
idea of gary coleman because then he
walks up and he thinks as a child then
he realizes that's gary coleman who's
the other guy it's just you know someone
like an epstein shows up and uh emmanuel
lewis is now uh meta world peace that's
it
emmanuel lewis also known in my head as
the other gary coleman right yes exactly
team beat magazine kathy ireland i'm
really sick so
sick
and there is no thriller album it
doesn't exist anymore wow
what nope nope there's a line stephen so
uh no one's paying attention
galen maxwell uh this is the u.s versus
glenn maxwell there were there was
another there's so many lawsuits which
you know
with android sex trafficking there kind
of should be so let me give you a quick
recap this is going to be happening uh
really now jury selection over the
thanksgiving break i don't know when
they necessarily recess they're waiting
to see the names of those involved with
the jeffrey epstein uh scandal so a past
civil lawsuit against jeffrey epstein by
the alleged victims gave some clues as
to who could be the co-conspirators uh
it listed
harvey weinstein miramax
and disney uh also the lost uh wait no
no no no they're uh there's a lot more
there's more there's more yes oh okay
wait a minute keep going down i think
there's a few more than just uh okay uh
you know universal mute co-conspirators
universal music group beyonce kanye west
and
sprint well i guess they couldn't get uh
they couldn't get kids interested in
wow so the lawsuit also says that steven
i'm sorry there's uh there's more
there's more people list more companies
there's more on the list there's a
couple more it's a longer list if you'll
oh okay the page uh that's right i have
it also listed viacom cbs the 1953 trust
roc nation robert kelly david boyce
milton brown nypd
and sony and sony moving on
i i hate to say this but i mean it
really is kind of like the whole world
how many people have been involved with
underage sex trafficking i uh don't and
no one knew it's a secret there's more a
little more
not a lot i'm sure yeah all right okay
so also named in the lawsuit u.s versus
jelaine maxwell the uh the the the
assistant to jeffrey epstein who helped
rape countless underage women uh def jam
recordings marcelo clare virgil abloh
parkwood entertainment sir philip green
black cube ltd terence thornton vivendi
sa um i don't know note that the the
civil suit was dismissed on standing
kind of like the election lawsuits um
but and you know just to to top it off i
guess joe biden actually just promoted
the judge and kind of federalized him a
little bit former vice president joe
biden former
president joe biden did that just
federalize the judge to the appeals
promoters into a prestigious federal
position he was the presiding i'm sorry
the judge who's been charged no it's
they change it to judge allison nathan
is now going to what i mean after her
promotion is going to hear the trial so
he put in a judge that's right i'm
looking at this here guys
even the new york times said that that
would be a conflict of interest
president joe biden did it former vice
president he did it this is from the new
york times one hypothetical question was
whether miss maxwell's lawyers might
seek to have the judge recuse herself
because the biden administration would
be in a position to derail her promotion
oh there's saying like it's a negative
if she did not favor the government
in her trial uh
be a shame if you lose that promotion
well look i don't know i don't know look
i don't want to attribute motive i'm not
in that business because it's not it's
not like the it's not like the biden
family has had anything let's not tar
and feather their good reputation the
biden family has had nothing to do with
underage uh sex trafficking of any kind
as i uh understand oh oh yeah the oh the
hunter bite yeah well okay i get it sins
of the father and what have you but
former vice former vice president joe
biden himself wouldn't he wouldn't
federalize a judge because he has a
vested interest in sexualizing minors
well
is that what he calls pumping gas i have
no idea right he wouldn't do that he
wouldn't do house speaker nancy pelosi
today advised former vice president joe
biden to keep his distance homes
insisted his daughter was not disturbed
by this televised nuzzle really former
vice president provided in 2015. there
was a huge bank of cameras about 50 and
joe who knows her leaned forward and
whispered some encouragement telling her
that she was doing great she looked
wonderful
twice
bam oh no body language doesn't speak
for itself
oh my god not today satan
and the kids used to come up and reach
into the pool and rubbed my leg down
so it was straight and then watched the
hair
come back up again okay all right look
what can i say okay you got me i should
have done more research yes jelaine
maxwell was involved in the underage sex
trafficking with jeffrey epstein and
there are like a million companies
who've been listed and it was dismissed
on standing and yes okay joe biden did
federalize the judge federal put up
someone in the court of appeals who may
have a conflict of interest and yes
hunter biden had sex with a few underage
people and maybe his niece and yes joe
biden is a creepy person with the very
least makes children sexually
uncomfortable and has an interest in
showering with his daughter okay all of
that may be true but i do not want to be
in the business of conjecture and if
that so it still does not mean that
former vice president joe biden would
ever intervene or use any kind of
presidential or vice presidential
authority to
somehow counter
act and
legal proceeding
and i had gotten a commitment from
poroshenko and from
uh yatsenyuk that they would take action
against the state prosecutor and they
didn't i said i'm telling you you're not
getting a billion dollars
i said you're not getting the billion
i'm gonna be leaving here and i think it
was about six hours i looked i said i'm
leaving in six hours if the prosecutor's
not fired you're not getting the money
oh son of a [ __ ]
got fired
well um
all right well look i will say that all
of this is still pure speculation at
this point youtube just to be clear if
you're going to fact check those things
i'm just saying that none of that adds
up to anything untoward right
coincidence yeah it is a lifetime of
coincidences uh and on that note please
smash that like button if you're
watching on youtube comment below as to
why you think this is going on and no
one is covering maxwell
and uh if you think that we should have
pedophile court where we make them go
walk out on a thinly iced pond youtube
thank you very much we're going to play
newest gender pronouns you can piss off
it's it's just um
he's back okay what are you doing no not
him pissing us
stop it stop it native stop it
you